sid
[Musik]
[Applaus]
london braucht
hier sind die ordnung bei rb kannst auch
du allein tragen sie uns an landtags sei
eine große gefahr für england warnte der
aliens die ohne chip in der heutigen
pressekonferenz in london
illegale hackergruppe nannte er ein
weiteres mal eine bande krimineller die
man einstellen müssen
red boß willkommen bei flauten die
kämpfe und die ausstellung
ich habe mir mal was zu trinken das
zusammen auf einem platz auf dem problem
vorsicht junge dame verpassen sie noch
das match weil ich sie ins krankenhaus
fahren muss
[Musik]
männer mir ist heute meine transport
ohne kaputt gegangen und da muss sich
doch irgendwie hab hier zu fuß
ich trete
gerne wieder
ein whisky den besten bitte
[Applaus]
[Musik]
groß
[Applaus]
ladies und gentlemen routinekontrolle
[Musik]
ihr kennt das ja alles schön locker
bleiben alle fragen beantworten dann
wird kein was passiert und keiner
paläste nadeln kapiert das ist ein
nichtraucher papst dagegen machen
wir sind das gesetz
mannschaft
meine geliebten rovers heute gibt es
sowas von aufn sack fürs haus werk steht
da war jemand gewaltig haben die keinen
der auf der baustelle sagen was mich und
meine jungs verärgern könnte
[Musik]
so waren die edle tropfen ist etwas zu
feiern wenn man nicht etwas zu sagen hat
sollte man das war gar nichts
[Musik]
ok genug smalltalk ein vögelchen hat mir
gezwitscher dass in diesem drecksloch
gelegentlichen backup zum ein- und
ausgeht
wer von euch jämmerlichen user kann mir
was darüber erzählt du hier
[Musik]
gut dann die harte tour
kleine gesundheits info wenn sie ein
jahr lang brauchen für kürzlich ihre
lebensdauer um drei monate verkürzt
gleich deine lebensdauer weiter den
oberlehrer spielst
ein kleiner spaß wenn er sich ja auch
die blühende zukunft unseres wunderschön
laden zu große mit handeln selbst
miterleben oder schlechter so ein
bisschen versteckte kritik
hat ihr sonst noch irgendjemand was
auszusetzen und ihrem freund und helfer
außer natürlich erde hat zudem weitere
gesundheits infos kaufen vogel & co
gesucht ist eine kleine pizza gehört
auch zu der zeit heutzutage kann man ja
nie wissen
[Musik]